hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
spekulatius schicht ist sehr ich habe
mir gedacht zum dezember gehört immer
ein leckeres stück cola zu dass einfach
geht super schnell geht und total lecker
schmeckt
[Musik]
ich starte jetzt erst mal direkt mit der
creme ich nehme dafür mein handwerk
gerät ihr könnt natürlich auch eine
küchenmaschine verwenden aber es
funktioniert alles auch wunderbar mit
einem handrührgerät und darf würden
nämlich mit schlagsahne
die ist schön kalt ganz frisch aus dem
kühlschrank und auch mein handrührgerät
ist nicht warm bis jetzt an aber wenn
ich das manchmal spüle und es warm ist
dann stellt sich die sache nicht gut auf
und da sollte alles schön kalt sein die
schüssel sollte kalt sein und da gebe
ich gleich dann noch während ich das
nächste sommerfest mit dazu damit das
auch richtig für ein steif bleibt
[Musik]
dieser habe ich jetzt schon steif
gestank falls ihr euch übrigens fragt
was ist wenn ich kein sahne fest da habe
es würde theoretisch gesehen bei diesem
rezept auch ohne sahne fest
funktionieren denn wir werden das ganz
lange kühlen und in der kür zeit wird
alles auch noch mal schön fest aber so
seid ihr einfach auf nummer sicher und
falls wirklich so diese letzte bisschen
an mixen fehlt und die sahne eben nicht
komplett streif ist hilft euch seine
fest dabei dass ihr 100 prozent auf der
sicheren seite sagt dass eure seine
komplett steif geschlagen wurde dass nur
kurz dazu ich mache jetzt weiter in
einer weiteren schüssel und gibt da
quark mit rennen habt ihr die wahl nimmt
ihm magerquark das mache ich zum
beispiel auch sehr gerne aber ich bin
auch schon von den 40 prozentigen
fahrrad bei dem rezept daher nehme ich
den 40-prozentigen ich werde da noch ein
bisschen puderzucker hinein sieben und
wenn ihr möglich könnt ihr spekulatius
gewürz oder sind noch dazu geben das
hebt das ganze noch mal so ein bisschen
und ich gebe natürlich ein bisschen
vanille extrakt mit hinein
[Musik]
mir ist wichtig dass in die quarkmasse
wirklich nur fünf bis acht sekunden vor
wenn ihr zu lange rührt und sind es auch
nur 20 sekunden dann wird die masse zu
flüssig und sie ist auch relativ weich
und ich geb dir jetzt auch sahne fest
dazu einfach weil die stärke darin noch
mal schön bindet und anschließend werde
ich das ganze unternehmen diesmal habe
ich nicht die sahne und die quarkmasse
sondern umgekehrt einfach mit einem teig
schaber
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die creme vorbereitet und
jetzt geht's auch schon direkt ans
schichten wir nehmen uns nämlich
spekulatius oder habe ich mir noch
gedacht dass ich sie halt rein dunkel
wie beim tiramisu und dafür nämlich ganz
einfach milch und ich habe mir noch
gedacht gibt einfach espresso mit dazu
falls ihr das nicht möchte oder kinder
mit essen dann könnt ihr das auch
einfach weglassen und dann nimmt einfach
nur nicht und dann habe ich mich auch
noch meinen back rahmen auf einen roten
retter gestellt soll als unterlage und
dann wird gleich einfach der kekse des
spekulatius kicks der wirt will ich nur
eine sekunde reine tun dann auf das
blech gegeben und dann wird immer
abwechselnd mit der creme geschichte
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt alles bis obenhin
geschichte ich habe übrigens drei
schichten mit spekulatius keksen jetzt
kommt noch eine vierte also ein
abschluss schicht aber die mache ich in
form von krümeln also dieser art combit
kommen wieder nach oben drauf da könnt
ihr einfach entweder einen mix annehmen
oder wenn die kein hartes kann sich
gerne zeigen dann gibt die restlichen
spekulatius kriegsende im gefrierbeutel
und dann rollt ihr und haut auch mit
einem nudelholz obendrauf ist ihr dann
wirklich drüber erhaltet und die kommen
dann nochmal on top und dann müsst ihr
mir versprechen stark zu sein weil er
muss das ganze mindestens vier stunden
kühlen damit auch noch mal alles schön
weich wieder so die kekse werden ein
bisschen weiß ja die creme mit ein
bisschen fester alles sitzt noch mal und
zieht schön und ich mache das in meinem
fall so dass ich dann am nächsten tag
anschneiden und dann seht ihr auch den
test wird am nächsten tag
[Musik]
also wir haben jetzt den nächsten tag
das ganze konnte wird die ganze macht
durchziehen alles fest geworden
spekulatius weiß geworden heute kann ich
das erklären wir haben unseren back
rahmen entfernt und dann haben
sie ja da habe ich jetzt richtig gute
schichten das ist hier so nur 44 4 322
schicht 043 also
schmeckt so richtig leicht im café raus
ja nicht so stark ganz löschen der
vortrag ist aufgefallen aber wenn du so
reagiert dann ist man ein gutes zeichen
ich stehe ja nicht was dabei soll aber
egal aber genau sagen was man so macht
richtig leckere kuchen und der ist auch
ein sehr sehr dekra
kurvenlicht ist der akku ist dasselbe
aber der der kleine schon so ist der ist
schon so ich komme einfach ein stück
reichen aber schmerzt auch in diesem
haus von kaffee sondern nicht so leicht
ich finde es mal ich finde es genau
richtig seite richtig lecker stolle füße
heraus ist gut weil machen richtige
analyse hier muss doch sein ich bin
traurig können mit den safe jetzt mit
seinem latte macchiato machen nachdem
die schnitte nummer passt perfekt zur
band dürfen würde nachmachen und auch
zum kauf genauer zu kaufland einkaufen
nachbacken alles genau steht hier unten
in der infobox und dann sehen wir uns
auch im nächsten rat selbst
[Musik]